england is looking at getting rid of
their their health pass they're looking
to get rid of their vaccine passport
system which soon will be implemented
this is a huge shift in the narrative as
of course there's major scientific
studies there's a lot of information
coming out that clearly is disrupting
this entire official story of what
they've been telling us from the very
beginning so this whole narrative is
collapsing this there's a lot of
important uh reasons to be extremely
optimistic i've been talking about this
weeks ago i'm saying with this latest uh
variant there's a big probability even
according to the world health
organization that announced that this is
going to be the end of kovid potentially
in 2022 so there's a lot of mainline
institutions there's a lot of mainline
doctors talking about what we were
talking months ago and there's this uh
meme going around that i tweeted that
specifically so shows you know the
talking points that this uh
administration and that these
authorities had from the very beginning
you die but you go to heaven that said
95 protection in may june 70 protection
70 protection august no protection but
reduces spread september doesn't reduce
spread but reduces severity october
doesn't reduce severity but reduces
hospitalizations november which doesn't
reduce hospitalizations but you aren't
going to die and then december you die
but you go to heaven so so that's a good
one that you know
that's essentially it's a joke you
youtube
down everyone can go talk to their
doctors yeah that's right again not a
medical doctor not here giving you any
kind of medical advice we're not here to
do that we're here to point out that
that there's elements of people making
fun of of what we've been told and and
exaggerating it because it's already
been exaggerated to such an extensive
level that it's hard for people to pay
attention to even what's going on yeah
you said that in 2022 we might see the
end of covet according to what the world
health organization i would point out
that maybe not the end of covet the end
of covet hysteria but that the virus
itself i've heard that it's supposedly
will be endemic meaning that we're just
going to live with the thing the
coronavirus that's one theory out there
there's another theory that this latest
variant is spreading so fast that it's
going to create natural immunity and
it's less severe less people are going
to end up in the hospital so all
everyone's going to get it because of
how fast it spreads to everyone and then
essentially it will kind of die out and
phase out from here because everyone
will have immunity
and and
this goes but when you look at
coronaviruses there's usually a specific
trend of how they kind of operate of how
they infect people and how they stop
infecting people based on those
mutations so if we're following the
basic procedures of how previous
coronavirus sars and mers have affected
the world it's it's logical to believe
that this is going to happen here dr
fauci has a different story saying
there's going to be another variant
that's going to be really bad but of
course he of course has an invested
interest in keeping the storyline going
because his entire career is
made on the severity of this sickness so
obviously as a conflict of interest
again these are some of the debates
happening within the scientific
community that i think are extremely
important right now and i think are
important to pay attention to because if
this is the case there's going to be
some significant political changes in
our society when we come to the end of
this and people feel bamboozled and lied
to about everything so this this is
something that we need to understand
politically socially and economically
because the effects of this are going to
be with us for years to come after this
i hope that we can as a species learn to
kind of live maybe in a more
coherent manner with viruses in general
i just looked it up 380 trillion viruses
inside of the human body 380 trillion
uh how many of those are hurting us
hardly any of them if any of them we
they live in symbiosis with us that's
the point
so i i don't see why that can't happen
with corona in fact it's clear on track
as you see the different variants here
the most successful viruses you don't
even know you have yeah they they sit in
your body they do virus stuff but they
don't cause enough problems for you to
actually care about it i would imagine
some of them help you i gotta go deeper
into it or get a viral just on the show
or something there's that one parasite
that makes you love cats oh yes
toxoplasmosis yes which a lot of people
in brazil have there's a fascinating
video of rogan talking to alex jones
about it and they go off i don't know if
that video clip is still on on youtube
but it
is terrifying to find out about uh the
effects of taxoplasmosis well it makes
people some people get schizophrenia it
literally creates the crazy cat lady
syndrome like the the the basic
stereotypical understanding of a crazy
cat lady obsessive loving of her cats
this is something that of course cats
have as a
as a mechanism for their survival when
they kind of have this virus that's in
poop that makes rats love them so
there's elements of this according to
some medical studies highlighting how
their similar effects on the human brain
that cause women and men to be impulsive
causes them to also be affected by this
in a very negative state but again
viruses are something that we have been
dealing with from the beginning of
humanity it's something that of course
is not going away and i i think there's
a lot of important learning lessons from
everything that happened within the last
two years that we should really uh learn
from and not repeat those mistakes that
were made i remember when i was growing
up i had a lot of important learning
lessons
like what was the most important one the
most important learning lesson yes oh
just you know reading about the history
of world war ii learning lessons were
really important for me as a kid
did you experience learning lessons
yeah i learned a lot of lessons is
learning lessons another leukism
it's a you didn't even know it was a
leukism that's why i said no and it's a
learning lesson
you have a lesson and you learn from it
i like it listen i'm going to make up
all the words i want to make up okay it
makes sense you guys know exactly what
i'm saying and uh
i might even make my own learning
lessons about this
well speaking of learning lessons if
we're going to move on i just want to
say before that i know i think this all
started because of a comment that said
it's really it's cynical to talk about
how everything's falling apart but
speaking of lessons and history i just
want to point out i i do see how it can
sound cynical and it can often be
depressing and there is often a sense of
hopelessness but if you do look at
history regimes fall people resist like
i'm sure there are some exceptions this
i won't say always but the like the
grand scheme of history and all of the
empires and all of the authoritarians
who've ruled over people
eventually it falls all empires collapse
that i think so i know china's still
going pretty strong but how long have
they actually been in power yes it's
true but have they had mind control
technology
and artificial intelligence which is
going to be the next nuclear weapon a
lot of arguments against uh anarchists
and mass surveillance yep a lot of argue
our arguments against anarchists and the
second amendment is are you going to
allow people to have nuclear weapons
well literally there's private
individuals and corporations creating
weapons that are even far more superior
and more powerful than nuclear weapons
that specifically is artificial
intelligence and that's happening right
now with collusion of the state let me
ask you what's scarier for you
the fact that certain states have
nuclear bombs warheads or the fact that
private unaccountable individuals can
post your web browser history
hmm
i mean i got a message i'm not worried
about nuclear war
you know what i mean i'm honestly not
super scared about uh i don't like the
spying or anything but i'm sure there's
a lot of people who are like
you know look people cheating on their
wives is a good example
yeah facebook knows if you're cheating
on your wife young women who are
pregnant don't want their parents to
find out their boyfriends to find out
big tech knows all of that and there was
even wasn't it like the nsa were tubanet
to pick private phones nsa agents were
caught
lube and tube in it to people's private
photos that they were sharing with their
loved ones unsuspectingly it's not like
they put published it it was private
messages between loved ones that the nsa
intercepted and decided to entertain
themselves with in many unspeakable ways
family friendly show you get the gist of
whatever two minutes how did they get
caught did someone kick the door walked
in and they're like what i don't
remember the exact details of this but
this was a mainline like story even
before edward snowden came out saying
hey the nsa are doing this this is how
they caught tsa agents also have an
extremely horrible record of abusing
their power with individuals that they
have to engage with and act with but
i think you were talking about a lot of
those stories carrie when you were
working in alternative media
specifically the stories that have been
significantly underplayed but are
significant to our way of life which one
was the do you think in your opinion one
of the most kind of egregious ones when
it comes to government abuse of power uh
abusive power in general or surveillance
both
um well i mean obviously what snowden
cracked open with all of his with his
i don't want to say leaks because he was
so careful about releasing it but
nonetheless i'm actually looking it up
and apparently it was snowden who said
that that the nsa would intercept nude
pics yeah so yes he said that he
confirmed it but there was even before
that posing before
mainline articles talking about this
uh which
again is just i mean imagine thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you